[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بطبيعه الحال انسحاب روسيا من هذا الاتفاق
اتفاق الحبوب الاوكراني سيؤثر بشكل كبير
على النسق الاقتصادي العالمي وخاصه انه
سيحدث ازمه فيما يتعلق
بسلاسل الانذاب
للحبوب على المستوى العالمي مما سيؤدي بلا
شك الى ارتفاع اسعار هذه الحبوب على
المستوى العالمي خاصه في الدول الافريقيه
والقاره الافريقيه باعتبار ان
واردات الحبوب الافريقيه من روسيا
واوكرانيا تشكل اكثر من 40% من من هذه
الوارده
روسيا بطبيعه الحال هي تربط تربط العوده
لهذا الاتفاق
لاجرات هذا الاتفاق برفع العقوبات الماليه
والاقتصاديه التي تسلط عليها الدول الدول
الغربيه فهي تبحث بشكل مباشر على رفع
العقوبات وعلى
الخروج من الازمه التي باتت تعانيها من
الجراء هذه العقوبات التي باتت تشكل طوق
يقيد المنظومه الاقتصاديه الروسيه بالتالي
اليوم الدول الغربيه بدورها هي ترفض اي اي
مساومه واي اتفاق جديد فيما يتعلق بهذه
الصفقه بين روسيا واوكرانيا التي طلعها
الامم المتحده
اللغه العربيه تبحث الى عن المزيد من
القيود على روسيا وتمنعها من موارد
الماليه لتمويل مجهودها الحربي ضد ضد
اوكرانيا وبالتالي اليوم نحن دخلنا الى
منطق جديد سيفرض نوع من نوع من الازمه
فيما يتعلق ليس فقط بالحبوب وانما القمح
والشعير وما وما يشابهه وانما سيفرض ازمات
في مواد غذائيه عديده مثل مثل الزيوت مثل
مجموعه من المواد الغذائيه وهو ما سيؤثر
بلا شك على الاقتصاد العالمي من جديد
[موسيقى]
حال توقف هذا الاتفاق بين روسيا واوكرانيا
سيدفع ويضطر الدول الافريقيه الى البحث عن
بدائل جديده من خلال العالميه جديده
وستنفتح بلا شك على امريكا الشماليه وعلى
بعض الدول الاوروبيه والهند ولكن هذا
سياتي على حساب الاسعار التي ستجد صعوبه
كبيره اولا في تامين حاجيتها من هذه
المواد الاساسيه للمواد الغذائيه الاساسيه
باعتبار ان العالم يعيش اضطراب اولا
اقتصادي ويعيش اضطراب مناخي اثر على
مجموعه من الدول المنتجه للحبوب خاصه
الصين التي تعرف تراجع كبير في محصولها
الزراعي المتعلق بالحبوب كذلك الهند
واستراليا لامريكا الشماليه وبالتالي
اعتقد ان الدول الافريقيه ستجد اولا صعوبه
في تامين حاجيتها من هذه المواد الغذائيه
الاساسيه وحتى وان وجدتها ستجدها باتمان
جد مرتفعه مما سيتعكس بشكل مباشر على
مستوى الامن الغذائي داخل الدول الافريقيه
[موسيقى]